jean-marie le guen le secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
leur présenter ce soir par thierry
perret qui bien sûr reviendra sur la
clarification intervenue au ps autour
d'une motion à vocation majoritaire
perrine tarneaud de public sénat vous
interrogera à la fin de cette émission
sur les réformes à venir selon le
calendrier législatif très chargé un
jusqu'à les clés et même au delà on
verra ça tout à l'heure d'abord jean
marie le guen
le climat politique qui se tend sur un
texte pourtant consensuel pense et on
croit y est on a bien sûr après les
événements tragiques du mois de janvier
les attentats à paris le renforcement
des moyens du renseignement présenté par
manuel valls lui même la gauche dans son
penchant sécuritaire désormais assumée
trouve une droite défenseurs des
libertés
certes avec la gauche de la gauche les
écologistes mais c'est un match à fronts
renversés
écoutez je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
posture de part et d'autre j'entends par
là de tout dans toutes ses critiques je
vois beaucoup de postures parfois un
manque de sérieux par rapport au travail
parlementaire parce qu'en fait cette loi
contrairement à ce que disent un certain
nombre de ceux qui la critiquent n'est
pas née des événement aussi dramatique
soit il est aussi légitime et
interpellative soit il ce s'agissant des
questions de renseignements non c'est un
texte qui est venue d'un travail
parlementaire qui a été engagé
maintenant depuis plusieurs mois
notamment par le président de la
commission des lois jean jacques urvoas
un texte sur le renseignement alors
évidemment il ya un rapport entre donner
à l'état les moyens et à la police les
moyens de se renseigner de savoir ce qui
se passe et les menaces terroristes qui
existe dans notre merci ce n'est pas à
proprement parler une loi antiterroriste
c'est les événements vous ont poussé à
aller plus loin dans la surveillance
générale de la population pas du tout
les événements les éléments de cette loi
c'est d'abord et avant tout d'abord une
avancée considérable je n'entends plus
aucun de ceux qui la critiquent
aujourd'hui considéré que
nous sommes pour la première fois nous
faisons passer dans le domaine du droit
les questions du renseignement extérieur
et intérieur manière illégale quoi c'est
ce que vous non les gars là non légale
non vérifiés et sans contrôle qu'est ce
qui se passe on définit un certain
nombre d'activités qui avant n'était pas
défini on les met dans le cadre de la
loi il y a maintenant des procédures de
contrôle une autorité interne des
procédures internes
puis après une capacité d'une autorité
indépendante de juger de la légitimité
de ces actions et s'agissant des
personnes concernées la capacité d'
interpeller en termes de droit en disant
mais comment ça on a essayé deux par
exemple de me surveiller moi oui il y
attend de la scion l'alimentation et la
faut-il faire ce procès d'intention à à
nos services de police et de
renseignement extérieur je ne le crois
pas mais n'est à l'abri non par
définition nous devons avoir un système
global qui est un système démocratique
c'est à dire que les choses sont écrites
il ya des procédures et il ya des
procédures de recours et de contrôle
c'est la première fois que les éléments
de renseignements deviennent des
éléments de procédure qui ont des
éléments de contrôle extérieur et
démocratie est à la fois contrôle
général par le parlement contrôle par
une autorité indépendante contrôle par
des gens qui prennent des décisions qui
ne sont pas les gens les plus
immédiatement opérationnels donc trois
niveaux de contrôle trois niveaux de
contrôle successifs c'est fondamental et
c'est une avancée démocratique
considérable
il y a par ailleurs dans le texte un
certain nombre d'éléments j'allais dire
plus techniques qui sont des amants
session décrit les techniques de
renseignement
là aussi les autorise surtout oui les
autorise dans la mesure où elle n'était
pas interdit à vous d'aller passer la
bande originale est celle où le texte
d'avancée
oui je suis frappé des procès
d'intention qui sont faits ou à aucun
moment on ne donne acte au gouvernement
d'avoir d'abord des avancées
démocratiques
moi j'entends toutes les interpellations
elles peuvent être légitimes il faut
qu'un débat et il y à un débat parce que
le texte
maintenant il faut voir il n'y a pas de
débat puisque vous repoussez tous ses
amendements
ils veulent apporter des garanties
supplémentaires par exemple le patron
des députés ump monsieur jacob il dit
qu'il n'a comme réponse que les
éructations de manuel 20ème et l'ump en
fait est divisée maintenant on le voit
bien entre deux catégories de personnes
des gens qui depuis le début ont annoncé
qu'ils participaient à ce texte qu'ils
avaient l'intention de le voter
et puis des élus qui se réveille très
tardivement aujourd'hui et qui prennent
des postures pendant la liberté pseudo
libertaire qui sont j'allais dire
critique pour être critique et qui en
fait sont des gens qui fondamentalement
sont sur une orientation qui sont sur
l'idée que dans le web on doit laisser
faire tout ce qui s'y passe bon voilà et
ça ce n'est pas admissible bien donc et
va en tout cas ce n'est pas admissible
ce n'est pas la position du gouvernement
et ce n'est pas la position de la
majorité des français qui souhaitent
qu'on regarde donc je le disais une
gauche sécuritaire assumer oui
sécuritaire ci est sécuritaire c'est
prendre les mesures démocratiques pour
faire rentrer dans le droit et dans le
contrôle démocratique des moyens d'une
défense de notre pays de nos concitoyens
nous assumons complètement et
effectivement nous voyons sous le coup
de la posture une droite pseudo
libertaire qui vient prendre une
position systématiquement critiquant
fait sectaire et et opportuniste et de
l'autre côté
effectivement parfois à la gauche de la
gauche parfois même chez certains
socialistes une tentation de faire des
procès d'intention qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être chez d'autres j'ai beaucoup de
parlementaires et de droite et de gauche
on ne prend ce texte sans procès
d'intention et on propose un certain
nombre d'amendements qu'ils peuvent
évidemment faire évoluer le texte comme
je le disais le texte a évolué des
propositions de l'assemblée nationale
par le gouvernement il a déjà beaucoup
évolué en commission il évoluera encore
pour donner plus de garanties pratique
donc ne nous laisser décramponner réel
est ce que ça peut vraiment bon
nous prémunir contre de nouveaux
attentats demain c'est un des éléments
qui nous met en position mais personne
ne peut prétendre risque zéro
malheureusement nous ne sommes pas dans
cette situation
j'allais dire c'est plutôt mais par
contre nous voyons bien qu'il y avait je
peux répondre si vous voulez sur
certains éléments techniques mais il ya
des dispositions qui sont conformes au
droit qui sont conformes aux libertés
mais qui donne plus de force y compris
les les boîtes noires qui vont être
installées chez les opérateurs indiens
de boisons va quitter la présentation
édition la maison on verra bien mais il
n'y a pas de boîte noire je ne crois pas
je crois que j'ai une discussion qui a
lieu avec eux pour préciser les choses
il ya simplement la des algorithmes qui
vérifie que non pas ce que vous dit tout
ce que je dis est problématique il n'y a
pas de contrôle mais simplement si vous
vous mettez vous sans qu'on sache au
point de départ qui vous êtes mais si on
constate qu'il ya un point en france qui
appelle par exemple dix fois par semaine
la syrie pour prendre un exemple
j'allais dire un peu simpliste mais
compréhensive et bien il ya l'algorithme
qui va dire tiens c'est quand même
bizarre que monsieur appel du roi et à
ce moment là qu'est ce qui se passe on
dit pas qui est ce monsieur on dit voilà
est-ce que c'est bizarre on va vers une
autorité qui dit oui c'est bizarre
et donc je demande à ce qu' il y ait une
enquête sur rien le rien de rien et
liberticide vonau dit il n'y a rien de
liberticide tout au contraire et je
pense que il est tout à fait anormal de
faire des procès d'intention il est
légitime d'effectuer un travail
parlementaire
mais ceux qui veulent se saisir d'un
côté ou de l'autre sur une position
idéologique sur une position de procès
d'intention le fond au risque de dunes
de casser cet esprit du 11 janvier est
affaibli et arrêté non parce que en
l'occurrence y aura une majorité je
n'aurais pas qu' il n'y ait pas la
volonté d'adopter ce texte sur un très
large rassemblement
mais je dis attention de ne pas donner
faussement des inquiétudes à un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens trouveront des
réponses positives aux problèmes qui se
posent ne faisons pas des procès
d'intention de l'écart pour des raisins
hier pensées politiciennes pour des
arrières pensées politiciennes qui ne
sont pas de mise
au regard des circonstances tout autre
sujet le gouvernement a promis des
baisses d'impôts sur le revenu impôt des
millions de contribuables on le verra
d'ailleurs bientôt dans quelques mois
puisque les les avis de déclarations
commencent à arriver dans les boîtes aux
lettres
mais cette baisse ne veux pas cacher
néanmoins jean marie le guen la hausse
des impôts locaux et là c'est vous le
responsable dit l'opposition vous le
gouvernement mais écoutez cet
extraordinaire
voilà une opposition qui évidemment
éructe pour reprendre les propos de
monsieur jacob sur le fait qu'il faut
diminuer beaucoup plus largement les
les dépenses de l'état les dépenses
publiques et qui lorsqu'on dit aux
collectivités territoriales écoutez fait
un effort de redéploiement nous dit
c'est impossible
et c'est effectivement l'opposition qui
augmente les impôts moi je suis élue à
paris les noms paul meningaud n'augmente
pas les impôts des parisiens
par contre à toulouse c'est + 15 % à
bordeaux c'est plus vieux apparaît aussi
n'y a pas de hausse des impôts
il sait avoir des hausses de tarifs ici
ou là non mais ça c'est autre chose au
regard de 2,2 ce que gère la ville de
paris mais il n'y a pas de hausse des
impôts locaux à paris il y en a déjà une
hausse des impôts locaux à toulouse et à
bordeaux je dis qu'il ya une certaine
forme d'hypocrisie à l'opposition en
juin les aides aux assurés c'est pas des
mairies de droite mais il peut y avoir
je ne dis pas que la gauche est parfaite
et que la droite ne l'est pas je dis
simplement à que ce n'est pas
contrairement à ce qui est dit ce n'est
pas le gouvernement qui augmentent les
impôts c'est les collectivités
territoriales qui pourrit bonnes raisons
mais privé de dotation large mais si on
prétend défendre des pensent dépenser
moins au niveau de l'état faut bien
qu'ils aient une baisse des dépenses
publiques
si on dépense publique qui baissent il
faut qu'elle soit sur l'état s'est fait
que sur la sécurité sociale c'est fait
et aussi sur les collectifs donc admirer
du riz mais aussi pour les élus locaux
en service vers l'économie a personne
ici qui crée deux étant des cantons
prétendez baisser la dépense publique
faut il faut l'assumer nous nous le
faisons pour 50 milliards c'est un
effort qu'apparemment la droite trouve
trop importante lorsqu'on descend des
détails degrés le trou mais elles
promettent le double ou en triple donc
je dis il y a et ça ça ne fera pas durer
on va bien aller aux élections en 2017
et avant aux élections régionales faudra
bien que la droite nous disent comment
elle va diminuer la dépense publique
taxerait les lauriers du front national
nous dire comment vous allez trouver les
4 milliards d'économies supplémentaires
demandées par la commission de bruxelles
mais les 4 milliards se font par une as
dans le cadre du budget il y avait une
belle ans comment écouter
elles sont faites il ya un budget dit
les choses
un programme de stabilité qui dit les
choses il ya un certain nombre de
dépenses qui sont j'allais dire
constater par exemple le poids de la
dette
étant donné que nous avons fait pression
oui vous avez à dire que c'est le poids
de la dette le remboursement de la dette
les intérêts sur cette dette aujourd'hui
par la politique qui a été demandé par
la france et qui a été mise en oeuvre
par la banque centrale européenne c'est
à dire une pente est une politique
j'allais les intérêts ne le relâche
heures vous avez comme moi que les taux
d'intérêt sont passés aujourd'hui au
moment où monsieur sarkozy lui emprunter
à 34 ans arrive tout cuit alors là c'est
grâce à une belle au meeting étaient à
bord la vox en europe avec un taux égal
tant monsieur grossiord ne fun ne ne
soyez pas polémique où je dis que c'est
la france qui s'est battu avec d'autres
pour que la banque centrale est une
autre politique que celle qui était
demandé par la droite en europe
vous avez entendu parler de ce débat
absolument bon vous savez qu'il y avait
un débat sur la politique de la banque
centrale falletti qu'elle soit
accommodantes ou fallait-il qu'elle soit
orthodoxe nous avons dit il faut qu'elle
soit accommodant elle l'est elle l'est
ça donne des envies heurta c'est à dire
que notamment ils se trouvent que le
poids de la dette et vend un lourd ça
veut dire aussi que les français les
entreprises françaises peuvent emprunter
moins cher pour soutenir la consommation
s'agissant des français pour soutenir
l'investissement se méfiant des
entraîneurs il faut savoir saisir ces
circonstances
ça ne sera pas toujours le cas on ne
vivra pas toujours avec des taux
d'intérêt aussi bas
donc nous avons intérêt et nous en
profitons nous au niveau du budget de la
nation c'est un des éléments il ya
d'autres éléments qui rentrent en ligne
de compte la baisse du taux du pétrole
là pour le coup je vous donnerai accès
que ces circonstances extérieures et
mais ces circonstances extérieures et
bien il faut en profiter alors d'accord
voilà je voulais vous interroger sur
nicolas sarkozy qui veut que la france
tourne le dos à la médiocrité il répète
que l'alternance et est en marche que
répondez-vous à cet argument un peu ce
que disait le général de gaulle vaste
programme
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait qu'il tombe
sur lui même aussi en quelque sorte la
médiocrité et vous savez c'est un
jugement de valeur dont je ne sens pas
que monsieur nicolas sarkozy puisse
spontanément sans dégager françois
hollande va fêter ses trois ans à
l'elysée pour l'occasion ils s'expriment
mais pas forcément là où on l'attend on
l'a vu dans une longue interview au
magazine society il doit s'exprimer
dimanche sur canal+ alors il s'adresse
aux bobos et pas au peuple que la gauche
a perdu on lave aux dernières élections
départementales
je ne comprends pas que l'on fasse aussi
se hisser exprime
il s'est exprimé très récemment aux
journalistes étaient peut-être tcc des
bobos dont vous parlez puisqu'il fera
une conférence de presse il a une
conférence de presse il s'exprime
successivement dans différents médias
comme c'est bien normal lorsque l'on
vise à différentes face à exprimer bon
alors vous appartenez à ce qu'on appelle
aile droite du ps je ne sais pas si vous
acceptez n'auront pas du coup le recul
ça suffira pour le des réformateurs un
comptoir exemple le sénateur maire de
lyon gérard collomb mais finalement un
accord donc vous réunit au à la gauche
du parti martine aubry en vue du congrès
du ps au mois de juin je résume alors
dit de résumer
et stable vous appelez la gauche et la
droite pour moi c'est contestable de
massue réformiste qui est avec moi
d'ailleurs beaucoup de socialistes et
même une majorité d'entre eux voient là
et nous avons fait une mauvaise de
rassemblement avec une aubry notamment
par les autres avec gérard collomb avait
plein de d'amis également avec jean marc
ayrault et à une karine période à effet
à plein de questions sur ce sujet mais
on va voir
c'est d'abord si c'est une éclaircie
pour l'exécutif des éléments de réponse
avec sandra cerqueira depuis des mois
martine aubry s'agitent dans l'ombre
fait de l'oeil à la gauche de la gauche
en vue du congrès du ps de juin prochain
et voilà qu'une fine est l'ancienne
première secrétaire fait motion commune
avec jean christophe cambadélis celle du
gouvernement donc à la ligne sociale
libérale pour bon nombre de socialistes
martine aubry raisonnable a fait le bon
choix
le message c'est le rassemblement le
plus large possible autour d'un pôle de
manière à ce que il y ait véritablement
une construction majoritaire de
du prochain congrès mais surtout de la
vie du parti ensuite martine aubry a
contribué à écrire le texte avec jean
christophe cambadélis pour une partie de
l'ailé gauche du ps
pas question de parler de ralliement
c'est une motion de gauche assure jean
marc germain qui appelle à un nouveau
contrat de majorité et qui soutient
l'offre et la demande
on a pu converger pour infléchir la
politique économique et faire que ces
deux années soit au fond ce que françois
hollande avait promis en 2012 il avait
dit il y aura deux ans trois ans
d'efforts et ensuite les français
verront le fruit de leurs efforts et ses
fruits la main on a défini ensemble dans
ce texte commun que ce serait la relance
des investissements dans l'avenir et le
progrès social
voilà qui passe mal auprès du reste de
l'ailé gauche du ps marie noëlle
lienemann refuse de commenter
elle dit ne pas vouloir critiquer ses
amis le sujet est sensible alors un
congrès de poitiers joué d avance aux
allures de déjà vu c'est ce que dénonce
certains socialistes un peu amer on a
évidemment une critique très forte de la
politique économique du gouvernement pas
seulement parlement mais dans l'opinion
depuis des mois pour ne pas dire des
années est normal où il serait normal
que ce débat soit tranché à l'occasion
du congrès un effet ce te ment certains
s'activent et notamment le premier
secrétaires et d'autres conférences ans
que ce débat n'est pas lieu on
provoquant des ralliements qui sont pas
ceux contre nature c'est-à-dire ans
facilitons le mariage de la carpe et du
lapin en entretenant la confusion
idéologique une confusion idéologique
qui fait aussi grincer des dents les
réformateurs du ps ya plus de congrès le
congrès la mort c'est fini assez
parlante d'une équipe vous approche vous
allez pouvoir réagir car une paire est
bon mais nicole bricq qui appartient
comme vos poils des réformateurs dit le
congrès c'est mort c'est la vérité non
je crois que c'est une façon de dire que
août à partir du moment où il y à un
large rassemblement autour du premier
secrétaire on dit que cette motion a une
vocation majoritaire mais c'est pas
parce qu'un congrès s'apprête à donner
une majorité encore d'ailleurs faut-il
que ce soit vérifiée véritablement par
le vote des militants que le congrès est
mort je pense que le débat du congrès
comme le débat du parti socialiste
d'ailleurs se tient sur un débat qui est
souvent un peu ésotérique est un peu sec
je trouve ce fameux débat dont parlait
gaëtan gorce ou jean marc germain où on
est entre énarques pour discuter de
savoir si on met 10 milliards d'euros
dans un endroit où dans un autre je
trouve ce débat à s'éloigner des
préoccupations des français les plus
passionnés français c'est l'emploi c'est
les questions d'identité c'est des
questions sur l'europe d'une façon plus
générale et je pense qu'il ne faut pas
avoir une approche trop rétréci de la
politique comme on le voit depuis des
années il faut prendre une ampleur
beaucoup plus grands d'ailleurs la crise
que nous vivons est d'une ampleur
beaucoup plus grand boulevard devant lui
pour pour être le candidat entre
guillemets naturel pour 2017 il n'y a
plus d'opposition martine aubry est avec
la majorité au ps
je crois que cette question ne se posait
pas vraiment on ne fait rien a posé un à
votre camp énormément ski qui nous avons
eu un certain nombre de commentateurs
interne au parti socialiste je parle pas
des commentateurs de la presse mais deux
socialistes qui sont plutôt des
commentateurs qui sont très qui évolue
avec le niveau des sondages qui ont des
états d'âme et c'est moi je ne fais pas
de la politique comme ça je fais la
politique où je suis mes convictions je
sais que les
on est parfois il faut aller à
contre-courant parfois la météo est
difficile mais que dans ces cas là il
faut tenir le cap
est ce que je reproche c'est
effectivement à peut-être certains au
parti socialiste et d'avoir des états
d'âme fluctuant nous je pense que la
politique c'est pas ça c'est on a des
convictions on les applique
on croit que la politique économique par
exemple que l'on fait et bien elle va
trouver des résultats on sait que les
français sont dans le doute on sait que
les français sont pas contents on sait
que les français voient pas toujours des
résultats concrets par exemple en
matière d'emploi mais moi je sais que
les grands éléments de la politique
économique sont aujourd'hui réunies ce
dont on parlait tout à l'heure sur le rô
le crédit le pétrole et puis que tout ça
va donner des résultats surtout que
grâce au pack de responsabilité on a
libéré les entreprises de 2,2 fois
qu'ils étaient trop importants notamment
je pense ou pme et bien nous ça va
donner des résultats
et ceci va entraîner aussi une approche
je crois différentes dans le regard
justement vous parlez du pack de
responsabilité dans cette motion qui
réunit donc beaucoup de sensibilité
autour de jean-christophe cambadélis il
ya vos positions qu'on a souvent entendu
repos les réformateurs il ya aussi donc
les convictions de martine aubry
gaëtan gorce parler du maillage de
la carpe et du lapin mais c'est des
socialistes qui cultive le culte de la
division c'est qu'est ce que c'est ça on
est là nous est ce que les français
attendent de la gauche le spectacle
qu'elle a données depuis un an où on
voit des gens venir sur un certain
nombre d'antennes dire du mal des uns
des autres
quels sont les premiers commentateurs
négatif de la politique gouvernementale
c'est de temps en temps des socialistes
sont-ils majoritaire non combien
sont-ils au groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
ils sont allés une petite poignée que
vous avez souvent décrit l sont-ils
majoritaire groupe socialiste au sénat
encore moins chalet dire sont-ils
majoritaires au congrès nous le verrons
bien mais on ne peut pas continuer comme
ça les socialistes peuvent pas par une
espèce de plaisir plus ou moins
impersonnel de se proposer toujours
comme étant les principaux critiques de
la seconde à la joue contre leur équipe
lors de mes voyages
quels gages vous allez leur donner c'est
l'orchestré mais ils en discutent il ya
une vraie discussion qui s'est fait par
exemple sur le pagne dans le texte sur
le pacs de reste posée il ya l'idée de
mieux cibler les aides aux entreprises
c'est quelque chose qui vous convient de
cayenne et potsdam loge au dessus du
patronat on n'y a pas c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait on regarde ce qui marche sur
le pacte de responsabilité et il marche
à 80 90 % et puis il ya des dés par
exemple il ya des branches ou non la
partie patronale j'allais dire n'a pas
été encore mises en oeuvre ou bien
encore une partie même des entreprises
pour des raisons qui sont qu'il faudrait
expliquer parce qu'ils trouvent que le
certaines entreprises trouvent que le le
cicr est un peu complexe à mettre en
oeuvre vont pas chercher l'argent du cic
eux est en quelque sorte donc il reste
dense qui a été budgétée pour le cic il
reste un peu d'argent alors que cet
argent là on le prenne pour le focaliser
sur une autre forme d' aides à
l'investissement
moi je trouve ça très positif donc si
vous voulez qu'il y ait une réelle notre
la cinquième place est en recul des
charges et non mais non pas du tout le
patronat auraient tort de s'inquiéter
ils auraient raison de se mobiliser
c'est à dire que le pack de
responsabilité et c'est un pacte par
définition il ya deux partenaires
principalement l'état les entreprises et
bien c'est aux entreprises aussi de
faire vivre ce pacte voilà
qu'ils arrêtent de s'inquiéter qui se
mobilisent c'est vrai d'ailleurs pour le
patronat comme pour certains socialistes
ont parlé d'un pot en première partie et
sa figure aussi dans cette motion pour
le congrès michel sapin aujourd'hui
n'exclut pas de remettre le métier de du
prélèvement de là vous confirmez donc
d'abord je laisserais michel sapin s'est
exprimé sur le sujet parce que c'est lui
qui est qui et en responsabilité c'est
vrai que dans des leds il à l'impôt à la
source et une réforme qu'il faudrait
peut-être expliquer c'est pas un nouvel
impôt
c'est une autre façon de prélever
l'impôt qui fait que c'est dans un
couple c'est aussi bien l'homme que la
femme
évidemment qu'ils ddd ses revenus qui se
trouve peu élevé c'est un impôt qui est
prélevé comme ça dans toute l'europe
pratiquement aujourd'hui il ya plus
guère que la france où on a maintenu ce
type d'impôt donc y ait une réflexion
technique qui se passe tout le monde
sait d'ailleurs que c'est une à une
réflexion technique qui est soutenu par
beaucoup de gens à la bouche
elle essaie lui aussi marqué de la
réforme fiscale en général avec d'autres
aspects il y avait qu est ce que ça je
suis sûr que ça doit passionné les
français qui par les avants oui mais non
mais les impôts ce qui les intéresse
c'est ce qu'ils vont payer et là ce qui
va se passer c'est qu'il ya neuf
millions de français qui vont payer
moins d'impôt sur le revenu au mois de
septembre
pour l'instant il en doutent encore mais
nous nous savons pas ce que nous l'avons
voté et il y aura 9 millions de français
qui paieront moins d'impôts les gens qui
avaient la première tranche d'impôt ne
paieront plus ceux qui sont au dessus
paieront moins parce que tout ce qui
était l'impôt payable au niveau de la
première tranche sera retiré de leur
impôt sur le revenu
voilà la réalité ça ça les intérêts
alors après rentrer dans le débat comme
adore ça tombe de mes amis est très
légitime à passer dans des finances
mais vous savez dit pas le contraire je
trouve ça si vous voulez l'impôt à la
source que tu une réforme juste qui est
une réforme efficace qui est une réforme
qui a adopté par tous les pays européens
elle doit se mettre en place quand
michel sapin et en responsabilité l'osi
la question de la progressivité de la
csg alors oui non oui mais ça ça figure
aussi dans le non non non réflexion dit
elle avec la modulant hier c est un nom
de pierre qui est qui et quand on a dit
tout ça on a l'air extrêmement
intelligent on est très très fort sauf
que je constate que ces 10 à droite
parce que tout le monde dit ça veut dire
que en gros il y aura plus d'impôt sur
le revenu
et puis s'est dit certain à gauche qui
c'est super on va pouvoir augmenter les
impôts des feux me permettre de me
présenter de temps en temps je dis
simplement que ça ne veut pas dire
grand-chose excusez moi de le dire tant
qu'on ne dit pas les modalités et qui ça
touche donc s'il ya des gens au parti
socialiste qui sont sur une autre ligne
qui est celle qui est défendu par la
majorité des socialistes c'est à dire
qu'on ne naît pas là pour rajouter des
impôts et ça c'est très clair on ne
rajoutera pas d'impôt d'ici 2010 est là
je le raf hier je le réaffirme oui je
réaffirme bien s'il y en a d'autres
enfin quand on va baisser lorsque ça va
continuer à baisser
on va faire ce que l'on aime ça dépendra
du retour d'en rajouter c'est une chose
mais quand ils ne savent a baissé au
mois de septembre je vous aiderai 9
millions 2 milliards et demi d'euros en
moins d'impôts sur les revenus qui sera
présent dès le mois de septembre
donc après nous verrons cela reste selon
le retour l'économie française l'argent
ne fabrique pas si tant est qu'on est si
on avait une banque pour elle fabriquée
comme au monopoly on n'est pas au
monopoly
quand il ya des ressources saleh les
impôts que payent les français moi je
comprends et j'ai été un des premiers à
dire qu'ils paient trop d'impôts
enfin les impôts qui payent c'est la
date d'hier bon quand vous vous endettez
faut quand même pas s'étonner
complètement qu'à un moment audition
fait c'est dommage mais vrai peut-être
payé donc à partir de là
évidemment il ya des impôts bon alors
néanmoins nous avons décidé même si nous
avons été un peu trop pas assez
vigilants les premières années du
quinquennat vu le jour il ya pour la
droite 30 milliards pour la guérir on
aurait mieux fait de ne pas imiter la
droite en la mettant à mea culpa
oui oui mais quand même ça mais bien sûr
un mea culpa il fallait pas augmenter
les impôts quand la droite non mais j'ai
un dit à l'époque exactement donc je le
redis aujourd'hui je les dis quand
j'étais parlementaire en 2013 régler le
cas aujourd'hui vous avez bien voilà je
n'ai pas changé c'est toujours le même
5e qu'il a apporté la preuve changé bon
donc je dis simplement que il n'y aura
pas d'augmentation des impôts ici 2010
est la baisse nos diamants
s'il ya des socialistes qui sont pour
des augmentations d'impôts qui n'hésite
pas à rentrer dans les détails qui ne
retire on n'hésite pas à rentrer dans
les détails qui ne se met pas derrière
des formules magiques
hier csg etc auxquelles ni vous ni moi
ne comprenons grand-chose soyons honnête
donc voyons tout simplement ce que ça
veut dire et pour qui s'il s'agit
d'augmenter les impôts sur les couches
moyennes ma réponse est bonne arrive on
est tellement elles n'auront pas lieu
c'est l'engagement du maire est pas
tellement le premier mois on se dit que
le ps montre ses divisions sur la
question fiscale
c'est pour cela que vous avez décidé
personnes parlement l'augmentation des
impôts ils sont jamais venus dire qu'ils
devaient payer plus d'impôts et compte
la question c'est en l'absence de vote
et de débat sur le programme de
stabilité cela n'a rien à voir à
l'assemblée le texte du du de notre
accord avec le rpt est atone en levant
remet des documents
notre trajectoire ça s'appelle le
programme de stabilité c'est la
trajectoire financière pour les années
qui viennent tous les ans et où plus tôt
nouvellement avant le 30 avril avant ce
n'était pas très clair bon maintenant
c'est avant le 30 avril il se trouve que
le parlement le conseil des ministres
remettent son texte le 15
il y aura donc une discussion devant les
deux commissions des finances de
l'assemblée du sénat et fallait-il un
débat en séance publique
est ce que ça change grand chose j'en
suis pas sûr et ce n'était pas possible
parce que le parlement est en vacances
les deux dernières semaines d'avril
voilà donc c'était un pas du tout
obligatoire de est-ce que c'était
nécessaire je ne le crois pas 3 est ce
que c'était possible
puisque le parlement est en vacances la
réponse est non karine l'idée avait été
évoquée d'un remaniement quelques
semaines après les départementales qui s
est révélé une nouvelle déroute pour
votre parti s'est pas roulé pas dire que
le remaniement
non mais
non je dis d'abord je pense pas que ce
soit une déroute je pense que tu une
défaite importante mais bon voilà il
faut en prendre la mesure aussi
deuxièmement
le remaniement ça a été évoqué certains
le demandait alors quand la plus tôt
pour y rentrer et d'ailleurs comment
sortir je m'en félicite parce que ça
montre que oui vocation à s'élargir mais
vous êtes avoir entre l'écologie
moi je pense que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui chez les écologistes est
quelque chose de très important
et j'imagine que évidemment il faut tout
à fait le prendre en compte et à un
moment ou à un autre cette question se
posera évidemment au plan gouvernemental
parce que je m'aperçois que la ligne sur
lequel le groupe semble affalé les d
écologie semblait avec cécile duflot
s'orientait qui était une approche mans
vis-à-vis de jean luc mélenchon est une
critique systématique et j'allais dire
assez assez forte du du gouvernement va
finir par ne pas porter ses fruits
d'ailleurs 90 % des électeurs
écologistes veulent autre chose
donc ils sont rentrés au prochain
remaniement je pense qu'il ya un débat à
l'intérieur du groupe écologiste entre
ceux qui veulent être des partenaires
loyaux de cette majorité sur leur place
ceux qui ont une aventure plus d'accord
on a compris merci complet green perrine
tarneaud de public sénat arrive avec
d'autres questions se marie le guen les
réformes demandées le programme pour la
suite plongés dans le calendrier
parlementaire au sénat sous tension
entre
ralentissements et embouteillages envoie
ça avec marie brémaud cela fait une
semaine que la loi macron est passée au
crible par le sénat une semaine déjà et
pourtant l'examen du projet de loi pour
la croissance
l'activité et l'égalité des chances et
économique a pris bien du retard
il ya eu beaucoup plus d'amendements que
prévu de déposer et 1600 c'est évident
que même un rythme assez soutenu
voilà on est un peu un peu coincé alors
pour tenter de respecter un certain âge
hand à la conférence des présidents du
sénat vient d'octroyer deux jours
supplémentaires aux débats en séance
mais après la loi macron le calendrier
de la session ordinaire reste chargé du
côté des certitudes la haute-assemblée
d'ici juillet va s'attaquer à la
deuxième lecture de deux textes majeurs
la loi notre tout d'abord sur la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république
la transition énergétique ensuite sur ce
texte le sénat et l'assemblée nationale
s'opposent fortement sur la part du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
français
autre texte important sur lequel les
sénateurs vont se pencher le projet de
loi sur la santé porté par la ministre
marisol touraine
la ministre de la santé qui devra
affronter une chambre plutôt hostile à
la généralisation du tiers payant aux
salles de shoot et aux mesures anti
tabac
la réforme du droit d'asile est
également prévue au programme
et si il reste du temps aux sénateurs
les textes en attente ne manquent pas
comme la proposition de loi sur la fin
de vie
ça va faire lorrain
sincèrement je pense qu'on a une fin de
session ordinaire qui va être très très
chargé et on aura une session
extraordinaire puisque par définition ne
vois pas finir le 15 juillet le cda n'a
pas peur du travail et il appartient au
gouvernement de calculer son ordre du
jour prioritaire de telle manière que
les droits du parlement pour faire de
bonnes lois soient respectées au
gouvernement donc de revoir peut-être
l'ordre de ses priorités
l'exécutif qui visiblement peut compter
sur les sénateurs pour ne pas chômer
on y arrive toujours mais quelquefois il
faut travailler même j'ose à peine le
dire le dimanche à venir alors oui et le
travail du dimanche ce sera sans doute
examiné au sénat début mais si j'en
crois un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
dans les discussions peut être avant
dans le nuit de vendredi réservé bon on
verra peut-être d'abord sur le projet de
loi santé après un long parcours du
combattant le texte a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure
largement largement tout le débat c'est
quand même focalisée autour de la
généralisation du tuteur pied payant
sans doute au détriment des autres
mesures du texte de certaines avancées
est ce que c'est un problème de
communication la part du ministère de la
santé annonce est un système dans lequel
nous sommes par exemple le texte macron
qui a aujourd'hui presque 300 articles
c'est vous dire qu'ils traitent de
sujets très différents
si on demande aux uns et aux autres sur
quoi on a été interrogé essentiellement
sur le travail du dimanche qui doit
prendre à les six ou sept articles sur
ces 300 donc il ya une façon de
communiquer un peu simplement je sais
pas qui est responsable est ce que c'est
les politiques qui ne savent pas de taxe
santé il est quand même un problème il
ya là aussi avec les médecins non mais
attendez c'est un autre sujet vous me
parlez est ce que il
à une faute de communication sur le fait
qu'on fait qu'on parle que du tiers
payant généralisé
on a parlé quand même de deux pleins
d'autres choses qui sont tout à fait
importante
on a parlé du paquet tabac on a parlé du
travail sur notamment tout ce qui est
les questions de mannequins qui sont
d'anorexie rexie et d'incitation le
député livier vers en avait proposé des
amendements sur le sujet voilà plein de
sujets sur la prise en charge des
toxicomanes les actions les salles de
shoot dessous et vous dites les actions
de groupe etc
voilà les actions groupe sur la
reconnaissance des usagers plus grand de
représentants a vu quand même par un
seul jeu touraine que quand même assez
soulagé presque ému à l'issue du vote
tout à l'heure elle a été très chahuté
la ministre de la santé il ya eu une
contestation
forte effectivement d'un certain nombre
de professionnels vous allez savoir
oui non mais de médecins d'une part
après les parlementaires font leur
travail
moi je comprends qu'il ya des points de
désaccord entre la gauche à droite sur
un certain nombre de sujets bon alors ce
sujet sur le tiers payant qui d'ailleurs
généralisé mais qui n'est pas
obligatoire beaucoup de gens notamment
des professionnels de santé avons avait
dans l'oreille l'idée que c'était
obligatoire non c'est pas obligatoire ça
sera tout simplement proposé d'une façon
très générale de façon progressive avec
un certain nombre de garanties qui je
pense au fond des choses
vous savez derrière tout ça quand elle
reviendra au pouvoir si elle revient au
pouvoir en 2017
elle revient et d'industrie nous aurons
un débat là-dessus c'est parce que la
far gone et dénonce une
déresponsabilisation des pavillons et à
l'encouragement à la consommation de la
zi qui a fait a fait des franchises
médicales
l'alpha et l'oméga de sa politique de
santé est ce que les français
conviennent que ça améliorer notre
système de santé
aujourd'hui il veut supprimer le tiers
payant généralisé
c'est très bien c'est normal c'est une
politique de droite il a une vision
profondément punitive de la maladie il
pense que les patients sont des
délinquants financiers
donc évidemment il veux les sanctionner
ce quand ils vont chez le médecin c'est
le but de la franchise bon franchises
médicales à vous allez chez le médecin
il faut vous faire payer une franchise
c'est à dire quelque chose qui n'est pas
remboursable réalisation et délinquance
il ya une marge
car je pense qui dit qu'il vous ne le
discours qui est tenu c'est que les
patients ne sont pas responsables et ils
abusent de la sécurité sociale j'invente
où vous avez déjà entendu
ce discours moi je l' ai entendu
régulièrement quand j'étais
parlementaire de l'opposition
les gens qui abusent un système sont a
priori des gens alors le mot délinquants
et peut-être un peu fort attendez qu'est
ce que c'est que d'abuser d'un système
bien alors ce n'est pas contraire à la
loi mais c'est contraire à la morale
en tout cas c'est ça qu'on sous-entend
et sociale et celle ci dont seraient
tous des fraudeurs est par ailleurs
comme vous avez comme moi qu'on passe
très souvent dans ce même discours de
l'abus à la fraude jour merci de me
l'avoir rappelé mais c'est bien présent
vous rappelez plus tôt de l'autre côté
donc c'est de ce côté là pourquoi
voudrais-je parfaitement équilibré vous
avez bien raison donc je dis abus fraude
voilà ce dont on entend parler en
matière d'assurance maladie
moi je conteste cette vision là des
choses facilité de nos compatriotes
c'est quelque chose de très positif
voilà mais je comprends très bien et je
sais que monsieur sarkozy à des points
de vue tout à fait différent peut-être
que la majorité sénateurs juste un mot
avant de dire ça c'est que derrière tout
ça il ya un vrai malaise c'est celui des
des médecins et notamment des médecins
généralistes et là il ya une réflexion à
mener c'est pourquoi le jeune et me
disent ah oui je connais bien c'est
famille est impliquée là-dedans mes amis
etc
donc je sais qu'il ya un vrai malaise
mais pas à cause du tiers payant
généralisé
c'est un vrai malaise plus globale sur
l'exercice médical parce qu'il ya une
montée du consumérisme parce que il y à
des sociétés de travailler de façon
sélective mission au sénat cet été dans
un calendrier parlementaire qui est très
trop même sans doute un jean marie le
guen aux charges est toujours trop loi
mâcon transition énergétique
la deuxième lecture sur les régions est
et c'est ça explose quelles sont vos
priorités ce que le gouvernement doit se
fixer des priorités est ce que tout va
vraiment réussis dont vous avez parlé de
passera et doit passer avant lutter
ordinaire d'été donc assez chargé oui
oui oui je vous le confirme
roger karoutchi qui a fait le même job
comme le même jeune que moi à parler du
15 juillet je pense qu'il est un peu
optimiste et on ne voit pas donc oukases
et de nouvelles réformes et râteaux la
réforme impossible
les places à bas avant le mois de
juillet ça dépend parce qu'il ya des
projets de lois qui peuvent recevoir
aussi des éléments par exemple je sais
pas si ce sera le cas dont je ne prenais
pas comme une annonce mais dans le texte
macro on peut avoir la mise en oeuvre de
la problématique dit des amortissements
la nouvelle politique d'investissement
c'est pas très lourd c'est un ou deux
articles et c'est quelque chose de très
fort donc si vous voulez il peut y avoir
une réforme peut être quelque chose de
relativement simple au plan législatives
et des choses qui sont tout simplement
l'accompagnement d'un secteur demandent
beaucoup d'articles sont un peu long à
développer alors ce ne sont pas
considérés par nos compatriotes comme
étant des grosses réformes même si c'est
tout à fait utile d'avoir de bouger tout
un tas de petits réglages du
fonctionnement juridique de notre pays
alors il reste très peu de temps et j'ai
pas mal de questions sur le droit
d'asile la cour des comptes qui critique
le coût pour la france 1 2 milliard par
an bernard cazeneuve a annoncé tout à
l'heure la création de 5000 places
supplémentaires au risque de vraiment
faire exploser ce coup alors en france
le ce que d'abord la cour des comptes
n'a pas rendu son rapport ce qui a été
promulguée ce sont des fuites sur un
rapport qui lui même n'aurait pas eu le
droit de réponse vous savez qu'il ya
toujours un dialogue a cité un
pré-rapport fixé et payé
8 la fuite je dis simplement on laisser
le temps à un rapport de se faire et de
se poser y compris parce que ces
rapports en questions sont débattues pas
simplement par un ou deux rapporteurs
mais par richard pas rentrer dans le
détail intervient au moment où il est
souvent le cas on a suffisamment de riz
au sénat où il ya déjà beaucoup
d'amendements médias semblent eux il
faut du il y aura un débat s'est
parfaitement légitime et c'est vrai que
l'asile en france dysfonctionne c'est à
dire que nous avons beaucoup trop de
gens qui prennent beaucoup trop de temps
avant de connaître leurs droits et
vraisemblablement parmi les gens qui
demandent l'asile il y en a beaucoup qui
n'y ont pas droit
sauf que on est obligé ce que tu ressens
de refus voilà et sur 75% 99% reste en
france
alors ça c'est un autre sujet d'abord
ils restent là parce que très souvent le
loup la loi existante pas la loi que
nous avons fait nous c nous voulons la
réforme et de façon à diminuer les
délais donc les gens restant là pendant
des mois et des mois ils n'y ont pas
droit mais à partir du moment où ils
sont demandeurs ils ont des droits
donc après à la fin on constate qu'ils
ont plus loin mais ça fait un an qu'ils
sont un non on peut parfois plus qui
sont présents sur le territoire national
ils ont parfois trouvé une vie de
famille et c'est donc ça le ca
dysfonctionne ça ne va pas cette
histoire de d'asile donc la nécessité
d'agir rapidement fédéral
on suivra le débat au sénat et déjà
l'ump et le front national se sont
saisis du dossier sur radio france on
vient d'apprendre que la grève va être
reconduite demain mais les syndicats
semblent plus divisés pour la première
fois il ya eu la nomination d'un
médiateur et pourtant on est toujours
dans l'impasse jean marie le guen
question est est ce que c'est la miss
qui ne fait pas assez investi sur ces
deux corps non je pense que c'est
investi comme il le faut je pense
simplement 28 janv
mais d'accord mais c'est la grève elle
est la responsabilité des grévistes y si
je ne me trompe et est aujourd'hui 3%
donc je n'en sais rien enfin il faudrait
vérifier ces chiffres mais moi c'est une
majorité de plaquage je dis attention
tous les salariés de radio france
doivent être tout à fait attentif à
l'outil de qui est le leur c'est un
outil collectif d'ailleurs qui
n'appartient
il appartient certes à l'état au plan
juridique mais il appartient d'abord aux
français
donc il appartient aux français et
quelque part à tous ceux qui le
composent
attention à faire quoi attention à ne
pas détruire cet outil vous pensez qu'il
ya un risque de suicide collectif
non je ne dirais pas ça comme ça je dis
attention au fait que lorsqu'on ne donne
pas aux français vous savez bien qu'on
est dans un monde ouvert
il n'y a pas que radio france c'est fini
c'est puis le rtf
donc je veux dire les gens vont finir
par prendre l'habitude d'aller sur
d'autres antennes et c'est parce que
soit les salariés de radio france
bon donc je veux dire c'est il ya une
préoccupation faire attention de ne pas
être dans un monde qui ne tient pas
compte des réalités il doit y avoir une
réforme à radio france
donc si on tient pas compte de combes de
ça on n'est pas dans la réalité
après il ya du dialogue où il ya du
dialogue qui a été fait notamment par le
médiateur qui a fait des propositions
qui ont été reconnus vous le notiez par
toutes les organisations syndicales à ma
connaissance aucune bon et je dis
attention
la radicalisation elle peut être tout à
fait destructrice il faut comprendre que
des réformes s'imposent également vous
avez beaucoup parlé des communes à des
économies dans l'émission il en faut
aussi à radio france
ah oui bien sûr eu pour un meilleur
fonctionnement enfin il ya des
propositions qui ont été faites et accor
gère d'abord tous les corps vivant puis
comment penser qu' on peut pas s'adapter
alors que le monde des médias vous en
êtes les témoins évidemment a explosé
s'est profondément transformé merci on
verra la suite donc ce qui se passe à la
maison merci beaucoup perrine merci et à
très vite